اذن لفهم اكثر لهذا الزلزال وما وقع اليوم
في تلك المنطقه معنا من الاستوديو في
الاستوديو الدكتور رضا عبد الفتاح الخبير
خبير الزلازل بالهيئه العامه للطيران
المدني القطري اهلا بك دكتور رضا يعني لا
شك انها منطقه معروفه بقوع الزلازل بها
وقد وقعت في تركيا عده زلازل في الاعوام
الماضيه لكن ما الذي ادى الى زلزال بهذا
الحجم هذه الشده وهذه القوه هل من مسببات
واضحه
هو طبعا الزلازل بوجه عام لها اكتر من سبب
السبب الرئيسي الزلازل المدمره هي هو
بيسموه سبب تكتوني ده بيبقى ناتج عن حركه
ما يسمى بالصفائح التكتونيه لان زمان
معروف حاليا دلوقتي طبعا سطح الكره
الارضيه ما هوش عباره عن قطعه واحده فمقسم
لقطعه العلماء يسموا القطع ديت صفيحه
تكتونيه هذه القطعه بتتحرك بالنسبه لبعضها
البعض نتيجه هذه الحركه على مدار او على
مدى طويل من من السنين
بيسبب تولد طاقه زي اي جسمين بيحتاجكم في
بعض بيولد طاقه الطاقه ديت مع مرور الوقت
بتختزن في الصخور المكونه للمنطقه الفاصله
بين كل صفيحه والاخرى
في فرق كبير جدا بين الشده وبين القوه
ممكن الزلزال يبقى قوي قوي زي الزلزال
اللي حصل النهارده
ولكنه مش مدمر لان شدته قليله الشده هي
رده فعل
البنيه التحتيه او الوسط المحيط لبؤره
الزلزال مع القوه بتاع الزلزال نفسه يعني
الزلزال هو عباره عن طاقه طاقه بتنطلق
الطاقه ديت هتاثر في المباني بشكل ازاي
هتاثر في الناس بشكل ازاي
التاثير ده هو ده الشده احنا بنقيس الشده
بناء عن التاثير الناتج عن قوه الزلزال
فممكن زلزال يبقى قوي وليس له بسيطه جدا
يعني عامه زلزال ده ممكن يكون في دوله
اخرى في بنيه تحتيه قويه
ما يحصلش نفس الدمار او في او في منطقه
اخرى داخل تركيا
ويعتمد ايضا على الثقافه المجتمعيه كيف
تتعامل مع مثل هذا الحدث طيب من حيث
الخطوره ما مدى خطوره هذا الزلزال من حيث
ارتداداته شاهدنا اليوم اكثر من مئه هزه
ارتداديه هل نتوقع استمرار مثل هذه الهزات
والى متى هو الى متى ديت الى ان تهدا
المنطقه ما حدش يقدر يتنبا
بمتى تخمد هذه الطاقه الا العلماء اللي
شغالين في نفس المنطقه ديت بيشوفوا عدد
الزلازل بيتناقص طبعا هو احنا بره تركيا
عدد الزلازل اللي بنقصده لا يكاد يكون
مثلا واحد على عشره من كميه الزلازل او
عدد الزلازل اللي بيتم راسه داخل تركيا
نفسها
الزلازل ديت بتبدا في اول يوم بالالاف
وبعدين مع مرور الايام مده اسبوعين او
ثلاثه اسابيع تبدا العدد ده ينزل والمنحنى
العدد يقل لما العدد يقل ويصل للطبيعي
معناها ان خلاص الزلزال دوت بتاعته انتهت
ولكن النقطه اللي انا عاوز اوضحها
الزلزال الكبير هو اساسا بيبقى هو اكثر
زلزال مؤثر هو اللي اتى على البنيه
التحتيه الموجوده فجعلها هشه لا تحتمل
الزلازل الافتداديه فالزلازل ليست خطره
الرئيسي الخطر الكبير قد عدى في زلزال دوت
يعني انتهى ولكن بتيجي بتكمل دور زلزال
الكبير فهي بتبقى صغيره ولكن تاسيسها
شدتها ممكن تكون اكبر من الزلزال الكبير
اولا نريد ان نفسر للمشاهدين ماذا يعني
زلزال بقوه
7.8 على مقياس رخته كيف يمكن ان يختلف
مثلا زلزال بقوه اثنين فاصله خمسه على
سبيل المثال عن زلزال بقوه 7.8
قوه الزلزال هي عباره عن مقياس للطاقه
المنطلقه يعني في طاقه مخزنه على مدار
اعوام طويله
في الصخور المكونه للمنطقه اللي حدث فيها
الزلزال
كلما زادت هذه المده وكلما كانت هذه
الصخور قابله لتخزين طاقه اكثر ده بيكون
سبب في حدوث زلزال مدمر لان الطاقه ديت
اللي اخذت مئات السنين تختزن
بتنفجر الصخور وتطلق هذه الطاقه مره واحده
فبيكون الدمار كبير نتيجه الطاقه الكبيره
دي الزلزال الصغير بتبقى كميه الطاقه
المنطلقه اقل بكثير يعني احنا عندنا في
المقياس بتاع قوه الزلازل ده مقياس
لوغاريتمي للطاقه طبعا داخل في معاملات
اخرى كثير ولكن حضرتك تتخيلي ان مثلا
زلزال قوته سبعه اقل من 33 مره من زلزال
قوته 8
كطاقه منطلقه عنه فالرقم واحد دوت بيفرق
من زلزال لاخر اه نتيجه زي ما قلت لحضرتك
نوع الصخور اللي حصل او المنطقه اللي حصل
فيها نوع الصخور اللي فيها والمدى الزمني
لتخزين الطاقه او الاجهادات في منطقه
الزلزال طيب تحدثنا قبل قليل عن مسببات
واضحه
هل يضحي ايضا
المؤشرات ممكن يكون في مؤشرات ولكن ما
نقدرش نبني عليها قرار جازم ان هيحدث
زلزال يعني مثلا المنطقه اللي بيحدث فيها
زلزال ممكن نجد في نشاط زلزال ضعيف لا
يشعر به الناس ولكن طبعا مختصين بيرصدوه
قوته مثلا اقل من ثلاثه ما حد يحس به ممكن
نبسط كميه زلازل غير طبيعيه في المنطقه
ديت قبل حدوث الزلزال الكبير او الزلزال
الرئيسي اللي احنا خايفينه انه يحدث فدي
بيبقى مؤشر ان ممكن يحدث زلزال ولكن ممكن
ما يحدث يعني ده احد المؤشرات بس ما اقدرش
ابني عليه ممكن يحصل بعض التشققات في
المنطقه اللي يحدث فيها الهاء فيحدث فيها
زلزال ينطلق منها بعض الغازات ممكن لو
عندنا اجهزه بتقيس الغازات وطبعا دي
متوفره وموجوده بنقدر نعرف تغير نسب هذه
الغازات في الجو فنبدا مؤشر ان ممكن يحدث
زلزال في بعض المياه الجوفيه لو في ابار
لو فيه
عيون مائيه بنيجي نلاقيها مستوى المياه
فيها بينخفض او يرتفع برضو ده مؤشر على ان
في نشاط غير طبيعي في المنطقه في بعض
الحيوانات بتهاجر او تكون حركتها غير
طبيعيه زي الخيول زي الزواحف دول ديت
بيبقى برضو مؤشر ان ممكن يحدث نشاط ولكن
في الدراسات العلميه السابقه استخدمت هذه
المؤشرات
للتوقع حدوث زلزال او لتنبؤ بحدود زلزال
وما حدثت واحيانا استخدمت وحدث فبالتالي
انا ما اقدرش اخد قرار بناء عن هذه
المؤشرات اديه لصاحب القرار يعمل عمليه
اخلاء ويعمل هلع بين الناس وبعد كده ما
يحصلش حاجه لان الكلفه هتبقى كبيره جدا ما
الذي يمكن ان يحدد حجم الضرر الذي يحدثه
اي زلزال بشكل عام هل ما تحدثت عنه عن ضعف
بنيه تحتيه فقط ام ان قد يكون شكل
الارتدادات مختلف من زلزال لاخر وبناء
عليها او بالتالي يسبب حجم اضرار اكثر من
غيره كل اللي حضرتك قلت صح يعني احنا
عندنا الزلازل بتحدث بميكانيكيات مختلفه
كل ميكانيكيه لها قوه معينه بتبدا يعني
اقصى قوه فيها في الميكانيكيه ديت بنقول
مثلا اقصى سته اقصها سبعه اقصها ثمانيه
حسب
المنطقه دي فنقول المنطقه دي قادره على
توليد زلزال يصل الى ثمانيه وده بنسميه
التوقع يعني احنا في علم الزلازل ما يسمى
بالتوقع ما فيش حاجه اسمها التنبؤ في
الزلازل فاحنا التنبؤ هو عباره عن تدي
المعلومه في ثلاث متغيرات قوه الزلزال
يعني لما يحدث الزلزال يحدث بقوه كم نقدر
نقول ازاي لما يحدث في منطقه معينه هيحدث
بقوه ثمانيه واين سيحدث سيحدث في المنطقه
المعينه اللي احنا حددناها
متى سيحدث متى سيحدث لو احنا ادينا متى
سيحدث ده بدقه
او ميه في الميه دي معناها ان احنا تنبانا
وده مش موجود في العلم انما احنا نستبدله
بما يسمى التوقع التوقع نحدد المكان نحدد
القوه ولكن التوقيت ندي له احتماليه نقول
باحتمال 50% احتمال 70% بحيث ان احنا يبقى
العامل الزمن ده بيختلف حسب نوعيه الصخور
ونوعيه الصخور مش مهش متجانسه هي بتختلف
حسب العمق في كل منطقه
ريحته فعلا زلزال فاذا كانت المنطقه فيها
صخور قويه صلبه ده معناها ان الدمار بيبقى
اقل لان الصخور الرسوبيه او الصخور الهشه
الرمليه او البيئه الرمليه بتعمل تكبير
للموجات الزلزاليه فتديكي احساس بيشد اكبر
يعني القوه صغيره ملهاش كبيره ولكن الشده
اكبر لان حصل كبير ليه او تكبير للطاقه
تضخيم للطاقه نتيجه التربه قيس عليها برضو
البنيه المباني نفسها المباني نفسها
بتاعتها قويه مبنيه حسب كود معين للزلازل
مناسب للمنطقه اللي مبنيه فيها معناها ان
هي تتحمل حدود زلزال فبالتالي الدمار يقل
وقيس الثقافه العامه للمجتمع الثقافه
العامه للمجتمع لها دور كبير جدا